all right kick it off with your winning
the poo impression john
oh father hello there citizens of the
reject nation we are here to check out
the trailer
for
winnie the pooh blood and honey and what
a bother it's going to be for our
childhoods and whatnot greg how are you
doing good john
i'm excited to see this i am excited too
i don't know what to expect and i just
know it's going to be great so guys
leave a like on this video if you could
leave a comment how's your childhood
feeling after the blood and honey
experience well all that other good
stuff their childhood's in public domain
now it's it's fine
it doesn't matter all that's wrong
[Music]
you know you're the first person i ever
shown this place to and why am i so
special because soon
will be christopher and mary robin
we were friends for many years and
they're out there
laid into it christopher
we need to leave if you're arrested i
really need to find out what's happening
there okay
the e or dead
son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this place is kind of cool
um did you say i was a pool
random group
laura's dead
they already killed christopher robin
that's what it looks like
the strangers pray at night
[Music]
that was pretty hard
wow
[Laughter]
jesus
yep
yes
that
is that like a messed up piglet next to
him
yeah things poo and piglet full on tusks
oh that's what you mean yeah yeah i
think uh i don't think it's going to get
any better than that trailer
no i don't think so
i think it's going to be
i think this is the best it's going to
be and i don't i i feel like the movie
itself
will
not sustain
the entertainment value of what this is
for as long as this trailer did if that
does that make sense like this would
have been a good short film
yes because yeah like viral short film
yeah yeah yeah because part of the
funniness of this is the fact that there
is no humor at all in this trailer yes
it is this is like an actual slasher
movie trailer and that's all it really
looks like it doesn't look like it's
really doing anything unique with using
winnie the pooh and laura it looks just
like a straightforward generic
like a super wildly generic slasher film
that seems to be a lot like you know the
strangers pray at night that's that's
the
main one i was thinking of when watching
this one
for some reason even though there's a
lot of different slasher films in there
it's funny in concept of just like
christopher robin uh because i think the
plot is christopher robin left them to
go off to college and then he comes back
and they had to fend for themselves so
they turned into feral animals but i'm
like they didn't look like they turned
to feral animals it looked like they
just turned into generic serial killers
it looks like yeah they turned into big
burly dudes with animal masks if
anything it reminded me kind of that uh
the the title escapes me now uh but the
adam wingard movie with the animal masks
too it kind of reminded me of that as
well and yeah oh yeah yeah yeah what is
that one dude next you're next you're
next you're next i kept trying to say
ready or not but i knew it wasn't that
kind of yeah reminds me of just about
any slasher movie like you said it has
nothing really to do with twisting the
lore of winnie the pooh or going
it deadly says this alludes to it
doesn't look like you're gonna really
get personal with christopher robin and
really twist that relationship that's
maybe what i would have wanted is
something that knows the source material
and is messing with it and maybe the
movie will turn out to be that but from
that would be a refreshing surprise yeah
yeah yeah if if the joke extends to you
know actual knowledge of the hundred
acre wood in the various ensemble of
characters and all that stuff
if they keep them with a personality too
woody the pooh and piglet like if they
kept their personality in intact in some
way
and not that they could necessarily do i
imagine there's like certain voices they
can't do yeah you know because that's
where the public domain copyright ship
becomes a little bit
like very muddied you know yeah you're
on the disney territory and they will
not be happy about that but if they were
directly rife in auto where it was some
type of oh yeah you know christopher
robin does abandon
it could lead down some really because
it's like if it was about them having
abandonment issues and then watching
what struggles they had because weirdly
once the trailer lost me when thinking
about it as a movie and not just a
trailer it was when they cut to all the
girls at the house that's when i was
like oh okay i never mind i thought we
were gonna do something a little more
interesting here yeah that's what i mean
like entertaining ass trailer i have a
feeling the movie might turn out pretty
boring
well yeah and i mean looking and no
slight to the director like i'm still
excited to eventually maybe check this
out in a in a you know uh is so bad as
good kind of way but i i you know the
guys made a bunch of other you know
schlocky uh b-movie type things and this
looked better upon first glance than i
expected just in terms of the production
values and the shots and stuff but
you're absolutely right it seems like
it's more concerned with taking the
iconography and then perverting it with
slasher movie stuff and like oh they're
gonna massacre a bunch of chicks and
yeah from there i'm like okay this feels
like two movies this could have been the
sequel to blood and hunting and you
could have done the first movie all just
about christopher robin and his new
soon-to-be wife
and you know just the torment that
bringing up his childhood will do to
them but
i don't know
this looks like yeah the trailer is
going to be a big part of the overall
punch line but i don't know i mean we
could be wrong i'd be very pleasantly
surprised i'd be thrilled if we do walk
into this movie and then i'm like you
know what this movie actually did a lot
more did although did all the things
that i was actually hoping it would do
or at least did half of the things that
i was hoping it could actually explore i
don't know like
that's this is about exactly what i
expected
and that's both good and disappointing
to me yeah at the same time yeah you
want a little extra ounce of that
knowing like we really studied up we
know our winnie the pooh and we're gonna
do more than just have a couple burly
dudes in animal masks that are just the
right animals you know i don't know i
might get a little bit more
cannibalistic about it because it
wouldn't be cannibalistic would it if
they're animals just eating like we
don't even call that cannibalism but if
they do like feed into that but it is
like
like they kill and then they eat yeah
and then jar the blood along with the
honey yeah or whatever that was at the
end it's not about you guys but i like
watching a bunch of women get killed off
definitely i love it it's a whole
there's a genre for a reason especially
attractive there's something just so
exciting about it that you just want to
sink your teeth into i want to kill all
attractive women
it is a feeling that comes out it is an
urge
it is it is something i i don't quite
know what it is but it feels good yeah
yeah this is the kind of things i aspire
to be like you know i see this trailer
like this and i'm like i gotta get out
there man
yeah and also you know with the mass
that i wear at night i feel like this
would actually probably be a little bit
more appealing allure
yeah
totally i i would follow these are just
jokes people these are jokes just jokes
we don't believe this
is thirsty you cannot prove the thing
you're saying
protective under parody law
this is a harmful speech anyway guys
winnie the pooh pudding honey
how excited are you didn't i think we
were just walking pooing all over it
yeah entertaining trailer to say the
least
all right guys we'll see you soon
[Music]